hello my name is Ron Dunham I'm a
Canadian from a company called
snc-lavalin a large engineering or
engineering construction company that
also invests in infrastructure around
the world I've been asked today to get
to talk about the youth youth
unemployment and the the kind of changes
that are required in the middle eastern
region to accelerate jobs I must say
this is a bit of an improvised session
so I'll give you a few random thoughts
off the top of my head the very first
and foremost thought is the the need to
develop an entrepreneurial culture this
is not a region where it is an easy life
to be an entrepreneur in fact everywhere
in the world is stuff but here in this
region is particularly difficult first
of all if you look at Steve Jobs the
kind of poster boy of of
entrepreneurialism he learned by failure
but here in the Middle East the
consequences of failure are unduly heavy
the example that is often cited is that
if you bounce a check you go to jail and
so on and this is this is substantial
discouragement for people to go out take
a risk try and make a business fail once
or twice and finally succeed as
entrepreneurs because that is a pattern
of entrepreneurial behavior on the other
hand to create jobs small businesses are
the backbone of job creation me the way
you create your most efficiently are
through the implementation of small
business so these countervailing factors
have to be addressed governments have to
make it easy to start a business right
now the regulatory burden is too high
the cronyism is too high where you need
almost personal connections to be able
to start a business in some kind of
efficient fashion and as I mentioned Lee
the consequences of failure are too high
create a culture that glorifies
entrepreneurs and you will create jobs
these are the source of this innovation
the source of the job will be the youth
of the region that's educated that has
the appetite to work hard that have the
ideas are constrained by the system from
a big business point of view because
obviously I work in a big business we
are we try to do our part these days we
break our our projects down into many
small packages in the on our old system
we would have for a large project we
would have two or three large packages
we would go and find two or three other
large companies to share the risk and we
would get on with business these days we
have some things like local resource
development initiatives but we will take
two or three hundred million dollars
break it into very small packages and
help people go out and win these
packages in fact we will go and make
people aware that these packages are
available and we will train people to
bid on the packages help them prepare
their bids and then run around to the
other side of the table and evaluate the
bids and award on the work this is a
very important part of community
involvement community to develop in the
encouragement of entrepreneurs in the
creation of jobs and it is part and
parcel of I would say the are our
current approach to business which is
compatible with the the needs of the
region no I've rambled on for at least a
minute and a half and I think I'll cut
off there but it is a an area that is of
capital importance to the middle eastern
region there are solutions but it is
really need for good good dialogue and a
coordination between both government and
private industry to produce all these
much-needed jobs thank you very much